kaiser so
um and international master 2932
interesting you don't usually see a
straight
filador like this it's not considered
very good for
black these days
um yeah white has very easy development
i'll just play bishop for example f4
looks normal
didn't really have to play bishop e5 i
mean queen d2 is also fine but this
looks
looks quite nice for white if i if i get
e5 in that he'll
i mean he's really lacking space here
and uh
should be six okay so e5 he wants to
answer with uh with an id5
the rookie one looks normal
his position is still quite quite
reasonable
um i would think 97 is a sensible move
and then if e5 followed up with d5 and
and i'm not
really sure i played this the right way
but he's taking his time here with the
queen v8 it was a bit unexpected
because he wants to play queen put his
queen on d7
um i always try queen a4 i attack c6
and my knight will come to d4 maybe to
f5
um yeah if he plays like queen b7 knight
d4
mission d7 knight f5 looks nice
somewhat promising
launcher of knight five is really the
right way to play his position
because he'll take he'll play rook f8
and it's not a great structure in
general
actually kind of like move queen queen
b3
i mean the end game with the uh split up
uh pawns the isolated a pawn
looks rather pleasant for white
not really a huge advantage or anything
i'm still most likely going to get e5 in
at some moment
and if c5 then knight five looks nice
after he's weakened uh some white
squares
okay so he's going here and f3 i guess
he wants to go knight e5
so i could maybe consider
bishop g3 so that i have f4 if he goes
if he loses nine
rk8 looks normal let's say h3
95 f4 he has to go back to g6
it's probably not the most ideal square
for his knight
um but it's it's not so bad
for him the knight is still annoying
it's not easy to say how i should play
this position i should approach it like
my instinct is to play knight f3
so let's go with that at least it really
restricts his knight stops him from
knight h4
it does open up the possibility of f5 on
the other hand i did take off some
pressure from c6
i'm not too happy about that
i mean if he he could play a fight here
yeah f5 i don't
i mean i'm i'm thinking e5 is probably
the right way to
respond okay d5 now
now this does look like good position
question is
my my bishop is really not great here i
wanted to be on f2 and uh
to have g3 in but i can't really do this
i can play 92 and then bishop f2 i guess
let's try that
not really what i wanted knight e6
is a good square for tonight okay he
doesn't go for it
instead he goes for a5 now i think it's
time to go back he'll be 96 and i'll by
g3
i expected him to go 96
this pins my knight but i don't think he
wants to take let's just play g3
um just preemptively at the rook on e2
and now i want to play knight
a4 he could take an a4 but then i'll
play
e king king v2 or something so here i'm
happy to get this in
although he actually he can play c5 and
then i'll take bishop c6 c4
slack the exchange okay here i think i'm
quite happy to get c3 and then king c2
on the other hand maybe i did weaken
mine okay
so work d3 it's playing quite
quite quickly and quite well
[Music]
all right rookie three we have to speed
up a bit c4
i'll take another piece really
wow okay now i have to suck my things
are going out of
out of control for me i didn't want to
stack a piece like this
at least it's still a bit of a mess
knight a4
and d7 at least i put my pawn there
rookie two
oh no
yeah this fell apart
and now now we have to flag them
which i have no idea so
i flagged him normally i don't like to
do that but
that was really a dirty flag
i wrote down for absolutely nothing so i
do apologize but
uh but kudos kudos to my opponent for
completely outplaying me and um
and finding some really nice tactics uh
c4 and bishop v8 was on a really
unexpected and